PERCENTAGE POINTS.
THE S&P 500 WAS DOWN TWO.
THE NASDAQ LOST ONE.
INTERNATIONAL REACTION TO
THE PRESIDENT'S TARIFF
ANNOUNCEMENT HAS BEEN ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY NEGATIVE.
CORRESPONDENT RICH HEADSON
IS AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
TONIGHT WITH THAT PART OF
THE STORY.
>> INTERNATIONAL MARKETS,
BUSINESSES AND ALLIES MET
PROPOSED TARIFFS ON STEEL
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMMD
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMMA
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMME
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMMY
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMMA
AND ALUMINUM IMMOOD IMRATLY IMMD
HARSHLY.
>> WE SHOULD TAKE THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
>> A TRADE WAR WOULD BE IN
NOBODY'S INTEREST.
>> THE EU WOULD REACT FIRMLY
AND COMMENSURATELY TO DEFEND
OUR INTERESTS.
>> THAT REACTION IS ALREADY
IN THE WORKS.
REUTERS REPORTS THE EUROPEAN
UNION IS CONSIDERING A 25%
TARIFF HALF BILLION DOLLARS
IN U.S. IMPORTS IF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP FOLLOWS
THROUGH ON PLAN TO HIT STEEL
AND ALUMINUM IMPORTS WITH
SUBSTANTIAL TARIFFS.
>> YOU CAN IDENTIFY PRODUCTS
THAT WILL THEORETICALLY HURT
US AND NOT THEM.
AND I THINK COUNTRIES,
PARTICULARLY THE EUROPEANS
ARE GOOD AT DOING THAT.
>> EUROPEAN OFFICIALS ARE
REPORTEDLY CONSIDERING
TARIFFS ON WISCONSIN CHEESE
AND HARLEY DAVIDSONS MADE IN
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN'S
DISTRICT.
BOURBON, A STAPLE FROM
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MICHIGAN MCCONNELL'S HOME
STATE KENTUCKY AND ORANGE
JUICE, AN EXPORT OF THE
SWING STATE OF FLORIDA.
OF THE UNITED STATES
IMPORTED STEEL AND ALUMINUM
ARRIVES FROM CANADA.
ITS MINISTER OF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS SAYS, QUOTE:  IT IS
ENTIRELY INAPPROPRIATE TO
VIEW ANY TRADE WITH CANADA
AS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT TO THE UNITED STATES.
CANADA WILL TAKE RESPONSIVE
MEASURES TO DEFEND ITS TRADE
INTERESTS AND WORKERS.
AND THE COUNTRY THE U.S. HAS
LONG CRITICIZED FOR ITS
TRADE PRACTICES.
>> THEY ARE FULL OF
PREJUDICE, DISCRIMINATION,
AND HOSTILITY TO CHINA.
THIS IS A NEW VERSION OF THE
CHINA THREAT THEORY.
>> VICE SECRETARY GENERAL OF
THE CHINA IRON AND STEEL
ASSOCIATION BLUNTLY STATED,
QUOTE:  WHAT AN EXTREMELY
STUPID MOVE.
A DESPERATE ATTEMPT BY TRUMP
TO PANDER TO HIS VOTERS
WHICH I THINK, IN FACT, RUNS
COUNTER TO HIS AMERICA FIRST
PLEDGE.
THE U.S. IS NOW SETTING A
VERY, VERY BAD EXAMPLE.
WHILE GLOBAL STOCKS SINK IN
RESPONSE TO THE PROPOSED
TARIFFS, EUROPE'S LARGEST
HOME APPLIANCE MAKER SWEEPER
ELECTROLUX SAYS IT WILL
DELAY A IT 50-MILLION-DOLLAR
IN TENNESSEE.
CITING INCREASES CANADA.
RENEGOTIATE NAFTA.
THE MASSIVE NORTH AMERICA
FREE TRADE AGREEMENT.
NEW CONCERNS THAT NEW